so we're told let g be a differentiable
function defined over the closed
interval from negative six to six the
graph of its derivative so they're
giving the graphing the derivative of g
g prime is given below so this isn't the
graph of g this is the graph of g prime
what is the x value of the leftmost
inflection point
in flexman point in the graph of g so
they want they don't want to know the
the x value of the inflection points in
the graph of g prime and the graph in
this graph they want to know the
inflection points the x values of the
inflection points in the graph of g and
we have to figure out the leftmost one
so let me just make a little table here
to think about what is happening at
inflection points
in our second derivative our first
derivative and our actual function
so this is
g prime prime this is g prime and this
is our actual i guess you could call it
the original function so an inflection
point are points where our second
derivative is switching signs it's going
from positive negative or negative to
positive so let's consider that first
scenario so g
so going from positive to negative
positive
to
negative
so if g prime prime if the second
derivative is going from positive to
negative what is the first derivative
doing
well remember the second derivative is
the derivative of the first derivative
so where the second derivative is
positive where the second derivative is
positive that means that the first
derivative is increasing
so
if second derivative is going from
positive to negative that means first
derivative is going from increasing to
decreasing
from increasing to decreasing
and the function itself well when the
second derivative is positive we are
going to be that means
that means that the slope is constantly
increasing and so that means we are
concave upwards so concave
upwards
to
downwards to concave
to concave downwards but they've they've
given us the graph of g prime so let's
focus on what are the points where g
prime is going from increasing to
decreasing
so let's see g prime is increasing
increasing increasing increasing
increasing at a slower rate and then it
starts decreasing so right over there
it's going from increasing to decreasing
so then it's decreasing decreasing
decreasing then it goes increasing
increasing increasing increasing and
then decreasing again so that's another
point where we're going from increasing
to decreasing and those are the only
ones that look like we're going from
increasing to decreasing but we're not
done yet because it's not just about
going from the second derivative going
from positive to negative it's also the
other way around any time the second
derivative is switching signs so it's
also the situation where we're going
from
negative
to positive
or for the first derivative is going
from decreasing
decreasing to increasing
decreasing to increasing well let's see
we are decreasing decreasing decreasing
and then we're increasing all right so
it's right there and then we're
increasing
decreasing decreasing decreasing and
then we're increasing
so right over there so these are the
inflection points that i've just
figured out visually
so if you look at the choices if we want
to answer the original question well the
leftmost one is that x is equal to
negative three it's x equals negative
three x equals negative one is indeed a
x value where we have an inflection
point and let's see x equals two is one
and so is x equals four so they actually
listed all all of these are inflection
points and they just wanted the leftmost
one